i want to talk about holidays this
holiday season
is going to be bananas but it's also a
gift and i'm going to tell you why it's
a gift
um shortly here but one of the biggest
frustrations i have
is when folks pretend that the holidays
just appear out of the myth that they
don't come on the same day every year
that you can't plan for them that you
can't expect the same conversations
over and over again and it might be
financially
it might be about money right that how
many times have we got to mid-november
and we're like oh my gosh i can't afford
christmas presents or it gets to be
december 15th
and you're like i don't have any money
left and i got to buy eight presents for
fill in the blank
that shouldn't surprise you that
shouldn't surprise you that means you're
not
living an intentional life it means you
may be out of control if you're not
planning ahead right
and even 10 bucks a month over the
course of
12 months and you got 120 bucks to buy a
couple of gifts for a couple of people
right
but that's number one but the bigger
challenge is
that we pretend that the same holiday
feelings aren't going to show up every
year
that suddenly we're going to go to this
same christmas eve event that we've gone
to for 15 years or 20 years or 30 years
and that same uncle isn't going to pull
us aside and make the same
incredibly offensive ethnicity jokes
or that same grandma isn't going to
try to pull your cheek off of your face
or that same granddad isn't going to
corner you and start hammering you on
politics and who you voted for and i can
you believe that the
fill in the blank we just pretend that
those things
aren't going to happen this year and we
may think they're going to happen but we
just always end up completely
psychologically and emotionally
unprepared for the
the aftermath for the fallout for that
dark plane ride home
or that silent sadness trip
that we the you know you and your new
husband and
your dogs or you and your older wife and
your kids
y'all just drive back and it's that icky
weird like
here's the thing you got a gift called
kovid this year and i know it's awful to
call it a gift but i'm trying to find
the silver lining folks so go with me on
it
here's the thing we have an opportunity
to change traditions
we have an opportunity to speak up and
be heard
in a way that we haven't before
millions and millions of us have dealt
with financial challenges
have dealt with employment challenges
have dealt with transportation
challenges have dealt with
mobility challenges some states if you
leave you got a quarantine for 14 days
before you come back you can't just
leave for a weekend and
hop back into your same life and so i
want to talk about how to set
family boundaries during the holidays
and i want everyone listening
all 33 people of all 33 of you right who
are
mowing your lawn or riding your bike or
cleaning your house or driving to work
whatever it is
how you might be listening i want you
all of us i want all of us
to agree right now that we're going to
set holiday boundaries
okay so here here's a couple of things
we can do to set boundaries number one
you remember that you y o u
are in control of your schedule before
you commit to
travel or hosting plans you decide what
your limit is
three days two weeks if you're married
or you're gonna be traveling with a
boyfriend or girlfriend
sit down and co-create a plan together
this is how many days we are staying
this is
when we are going to leave and then you
are going to announce those plans to
somebody else
whether it be your mother your dad your
in-laws the multiple
in-laws you have to go to your dad's
new wife and your mom's ex-husband
whoever you're going to
you decide you set the schedule you
determine it
and by the way don't drive or fly
thousands of
miles to a place that's inhospitable or
threatening
just say no just say this year hey we're
not gonna we're not traveling
and don't lie and say well we can't this
year but you could
just say i'm not gonna come this year
i'm gonna send gifts instead i hope we
can all facetime
here's what we're gonna do but you set
your boundaries
be honest about it stand up tall about
it and listen
if you do go and you say i'm going to
show up for three days do not go
and whine the entire time you're there
that's like bringing poison to the group
that makes you the problem it's a waste
of energy it's a waste of time
it just brings everybody's moments down
if you're gonna go
go with a smile on your face go with joy
in your heart
right if you are so selfish that you
cannot honor your grandparents with the
night free from beer and cell phones
if you'll just comb your hair with a
part for one night tuck your shirt in
honor and respect him nah dude that's
not me bro i gotta be true to myself
shut up dude honor your grandparents or
don't go
don't go you play dress-up on friday
back when we used to be able to go to
concerts and you'd get all dolled up for
whatever concert you were going to dudes
you'd be like i got my leather pants and
my
my cool my cool boots or whatever it is
i don't know what you got dressed up
but you can get dressed up for concerts
you can get dressed up for dates you can
pretend for a night or two with your
grandparents you can pretend for a night
or two with your parents
dress up alright so number two decide
beforehand what you won't tolerate
and stick to it for example thanksgiving
is just a couple of weeks after the
election
i'm hoping we have a president by then
we might not if you don't want to talk
about politics send an email
beforehand that says we will not discuss
politics this will be a politics
free thanksgiving period we will not
talk about it
and if somebody violates your boundaries
when you're there walk
out or ask for a guest list of who's
going to be there
and if someone says hey i want to take a
bunch of pictures of your kids say
no you cannot take pictures of my child
and post them on social media if that's
not what you want if you don't mind that
then rock and roll
or if you have a alcoholic relative who
puts you and your family in danger when
they're drunk or they make everything
weird
you say no and here's the thing just
walk out
just walk out and if you have situations
where somebody's not safe and you can't
afford a hotel room so in case you have
to leave
then don't go don't go you get to own
you okay number three have a plan when
things escalate what we're just talking
about if somebody
um always wants to front hug real tight
and they start coming in
every year they're front hugging uncle
uncle whoever
you can say stop please i don't like
that
or that one uncle guys who always grabs
you by the
by the neck or behind the ear you can
look at them and firmly say
hey stop grabbing me please be
direct have a few phrases ready to go
please stop hugging and kissing my kids
period
and if she keeps doing it or he keeps
doing it leave right
if uncle whoever won't stop talking bad
about a particular group of people
people who don't look like you from
different religions than you different
geographic locations in you
you can look them in the eye and say
please stop
please don't talk about that group in
front of my family like that thank you
and if they continue this my house i can
talk to i want to
bye felicia i'm out i'm going to leave
see you later
and it doesn't have to be dramatic and
it's not a big stomp out you know why
because you're a grown-up
just going to take your kids and say
you'll have a great night and we will
see you tomorrow
or thank you so much and we're gonna
head back and then you and your family
can have a nutrition night off and just
eat ice cream until your brains come out
all right um whatever it is set your
boundaries and then have a plan for when
things escalate and here's number four
going back to the grandparents thing
understand your role
if you're a guest at someone else's
house recognize that you don't have the
same authority
as you might in your own house if you
are a boyfriend
or a girlfriend or you're visiting your
in-laws
keep in mind that you can respect their
home
be a person of dignity right
if you are uh going with somebody to
their
parents house for thanksgiving whether
you're married to him or you're just
visiting y'all just dating
that's not about you it's about them so
if your father and they'll ask you to do
some weird thing
if your mother-in-law asks you to you
know get on the roof
on the hou on the house and i mean on
the roof and re-roof the house or
hey tonight we're gonna go do a weird
family thing where we
i don't know fill in the blank with
whatever weird things your family does
just say cool i'm in or if it violates
your boundaries just say i'm gonna step
out tonight i'm gonna head to a hotel
you'll have a great
fun time don't make a scene don't be
dramatic about it but understand your
role
and if you can't pretend if you can't
dress up if you can't honor your parents
and your grandparents
for one night for two nights god help
you man just don't go
just don't go and make the holidays the
moment when you
yeah yeah show them do that enough do
that in july
okay and here's a note to um parents of
adult children
this is for parents out there if your
kids can't travel to see you because of
finances and other plans
let them off the hook of course you want
to see your grandkids
of course you do of course you
have missed out on everything because of
covet
of course you've been nervous and scared
and lonely but
beating up and guilt-tripping your adult
children helps nobody
it puts them in situations that they
can't deal with
financially it puts them in stressful
emotional situations
be the grown grown grown grown-ups and
you might have to let go of that fantasy
and that picture you had of this
gathering this special meal this photo
by a tree
and you're going to have to create a new
picture for what holidays are going to
look like this year
if your kids can't make it choose
beforehand you're not going to talk bad
about them you're not going to guilt
trip them
but you're going to immediately go into
well what's a new picture mode
we're going to have a uh we had to do my
mom's 70th birthday this year
via zoom was it ideal nope was it
hilarious and fun yup
ended up being a blast right whatever
the new thing is going to look like this
year
go for it everybody be adults everybody
be compassionate with one another
this is the year to come up with new
boundaries
this is the year to come up with new
traditions this is the year to
double down on respect and dignity
and honoring one another instead of like
yeah dude i always wear my leather pants
and no
shirt to holidays that's got to be me
dude stop
quit look around the world man that kind
of nonsense is killing us all
be cool be cool right good okay that's
my
that's my discussion on family
boundaries at the holidays
let's all agree we're going to love each
other through the holiday season
it's going to be hard it's going to be
cold it's going to be a mess
we're going to just got off the heels of
the election it's going to take all of
us to be grown-ups
all of us to love each other and to
smile for crying out loud